you see this wasp here it's called a
tarantula hawk if one happens to sting
you you're going to start to freak out
this is because it has perhaps the most
powerful stink among insects the pain is
positively electric no joke the
recommendation from an actual scientific
paper is to just lie down and scream ah
your natural response will probably be
to run around frantically you're only
going to fall down and hurt yourself
just lie down start screen here's the
good news the risk of this thing is
pretty look for all its might the
tarantula hawk is docile that's because
its thing is so astonishingly powerful
that everything around it has learned to
leave it beat do better lookout though
of your tarantula tarantula has somehow
mastered the English language to
understand what I'm saying
what's rajala hawk is so called because
of torment the spiders and turns them
into food now for itself before its
young when one finds a tarantula that
approaches cautious on account of
spiders giant fangs but inevitably the
wasp gets under the spider and flips it
on its back then drives its stinger and
the unfortunate arachnids belly the
tarantula is instantly paralyzed which
allows the loss to drag it into the
Burrow here it lays an egg on it
conceals the doom spider inside when the
egg hatches into a larva it devours the
spider alive and this can take weeks so
if you get stung by tarantula hawk just
remember the things could be much worse
for you and help great excuse to lie
down take the load ah ah ah ah